the Trap is is that you have to go build
a FICO score and the way you build a
FICO score is you go in debt why do I do
that so that I can borrow money why do I
go into why do I borrow money so I can
build my FICO score why do I build my
FICO score so I can borrow money why do
I borrow money so I can build my FICO
score why do I build my FICO score so I
can borrow money and you it's a dog
chasing its tail and suddenly you're an
American making $100,000 a year and 100%
of your money goes out to some stupid
butt bank because you worshiped at the
altar of the great FICO and that's what
your friend friends are doing and some
of your their parents are doing but it's
not smart